i looked at the senate the other day
this was just yesterday they were having
a debate over
uh it was it wasn't even a debate over
masks but it became a debate over masks
and i realized that the womanish
sherrod brown is exactly the kind of man
that this exactly the kind of problem
that candace owens was talking about
because on the floor of the u.s senate
what is supposed to be the greatest
deliberative body in the world
it broke out into bickering over who was
going to wear
a filthy cloth cloth mask over their
face senator from ohio i'd start by
asking the presiding officer to please
wear a mask
as he speaks and people below him or i
can't tell you what to do but
i know that the behavior i don't wear a
mask when i'm speaking like
most senators well i'm most sensitive
i don't need your instruction from i
know you don't need my instruction but i
there clearly isn't much interest in
this body in public health
we have a president who hasn't shown up
at the coronavirus task force
meeting in months we have a majority
leader that calls us back here
to vote on an unqualified nominee and
and at the same time to vote for judge
after judge after judge
exposing all the people who can't say
anything i understand
the people in front of you and the
presiding officer and expose all the
staff here
and the the majority leader just doesn't
seem to care
that is so embarrassing for sherrod
brown
sherrod brown should be very ashamed of
himself his family should be very
ashamed
to share a last name with that
individual
he shows up to the floor of the united
states senate where you were supposed to
make
persuasive speeches grand oratory
on the important public matters of the
day and what does he choose to do he
chooses to whine
and nag and passive aggressively
needle the presiding senator here that
would be a republican dan sullivan
for not wearing a cloth mask when he's
many many many many many
feet away from anybody even let's just
say for a minute that the masks are like
super duper effective let's just
let's go with that hypothetical dan
sullivan not wearing a mask when he's
so far away from everybody ain't going
to do anything it doesn't matter at all
but sheridan i want to well you
need to wear a mask i can't tell what
everyone else what to do but i'm telling
you what to do but actually he can't
sherrod brown has no right to tell dan
sullivan what to do especially as he's
presiding over this this hearing and
and dan sullivan responds in a manly way
he goes you don't you don't get to
lecture me about anything
no i'm going to sit here without my mask
because i'm speaking like an adult so
no sorry yeah and you're when you're
making us vote right that's your job to
you're a senator your job is to vote
and you're making this for unqualified
candidates okay if you think the
candidate's unqualified
make a speech about that don't just nag
and needle and whine it's pathetic
i feel like i'm don corleone talking to
johnny fontaine i want to shake sherrod
branson you can act like a man
what's the matter with you what's the
matter with this guy what's the matter
with our culture
that is not how men are supposed to
behave it's not how women are supposed
to behave
and it's certainly men should not be
doing a very
caricatured ridiculous impression of
such a
womanish ish sort of behavior
it's absolutely pathetic i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you